- Welcome to another episode
on my channel Firm Learning.
My name is Heinrich and
as you know, on my channel
I want to help you to become successful
in the first years of your career.
Here today I'm once again
back at my university
of Munich, this is the
place where I studied
business and philosophy
during my undergrad.
And the topic of today's
video is private university
versus public university.
Private school versus public school.
And the question is, which one is better?
Is private university
really worth the money?
Is it worth the investment
of your time, of your effort?
And I want to reflect on this exactly here
at my old university.
Because indeed, while I
did my bachelor in Munich,
in parallel to that I
completed a semester abroad
at Bocconi University in Milan,
which is a private business school,
and then later continued
to do a master in finance
and accounting at the London
School of Economics in London.
So indeed the question
is, which one is better?
This is what we're going
to talk about today.
So before we jump into the
details of the pros and cons
of public versus private universities,
I first wanna specify a bit more
what exactly I mean by
this public university.
Because I know that here there
are significant differences,
also country by country, especially also,
on the wider regions.
So for instance I know that for sure if,
in a US context, you talk
about a public university,
the universities that there you would have
in your mind are probably
very different than what
you would talk about in,
for instance, in German,
or broader European context.
Because indeed here in
Germany public universities,
like the University of Munich,
are quite good indeed.
And indeed this is I trust
similar in many other
European countries as well.
So in the context of this
video I will rather talk
about this more European type of system
whereby the public university
might not necessarily have
the reputation of some of
the very best private ones,
they're still considered to be good,
and to some extent also competitive,
and some of them even target universities,
but we are going to
talk about this concept
a bit more in a couple of minutes.
I will now talk about
four aspects where private
universities potentially
are a bit different
than public universities.
And the first one is the
richness of experience.
And this is now especially
relevant when you compare
private business schools
to public, big universities
like for instance
the University of Munich.
And for me one of the
key reasons why I decided
to start my undergraduate
studies here in Munich,
compared to for instance
also some German private
business schools that
exist for sure as well,
was really the opportunity
to study different types
of subjects, different
types of degree programs.
And personally I did indeed
study business and philosophy,
but even if you're not willing to complete
two full degrees, if you're
just enrolled in a business
program, and then just
take individual lectures,
individual classes on
some other topics as well,
for me this was one of the
key parts of the experience,
of studying in an undergraduate degree,
and this is of course
often not really possible
in a private business school.
Maybe if you compare
this to the London School
of Economics and Political Sciences,
which is the full name of the school,
there yes there were
some other opportunities,
but for instance at my MBA,
I only had the opportunity
to take business classes.
And while these were
for sure high quality,
and very interesting and
relevant business classes,
there I missed this
opportunity to go beyond
my core subject.
Same thing was true at
the University of Bocconi,
which is indeed an Italian
business school as well.
And this then also
translates just to the size
and magnitude of university.
So here in Munich, 50,000
students are studying.
This comes with lots of
extracurricular activities,
organizations, other
opportunities that you could
be part of, in parallel
to studying in university.
And while things like that exist as well
in these private schools,
these are often much smaller,
and by that also just the sheer amount
and opportunities of
organizations, activities,
societies, that you can
be part of, is limited,
this is at least what I strongly felt.
Next point I wanna talk about
is the quality of the teaching.
The quality of the education
that is being delivered to you.
And here I'd assume that
many people would argue
that yes the private
universities have an advantage,
and of course this might also be the case,
especially because due
to the better funding
of the private universities,
there you will often have
smaller group sizes instead
of sitting in a class
with 800, 900 other students
as I often experienced it,
here at the University of Munich,
in universities like
the LSE where I studied,
or Boccani in Milan, or the
later of course also the MBA,
the class sizes were
significantly smaller,
contributing to a better
learning environment, I'd say.
And here now, right now,
I'm standing in front
of the business faculty where
I studied here in Munich,
and indeed it was the case
that while the classes
were often larger, especially the later,
in the third, fourth, fifth,
sixth semester of university,
you had courses, you
had seminars where then
the group sizes were smaller as well,
so I wouldn't say it's
this black and white
when you compare these
two types of universities,
though indeed on average,
I would say it is correct
that these interactions are
richer, are in smaller groups,
in the private universities.
But here also I wanna say that in general
the quality of the lectures,
the quality of the teachings,
this had not a lower quality in Munich,
here I also had some excellent lectures,
excellent classes delivered
by excellent professors,
so this I'd say was rather similar,
though again quality of the groups,
smaller group sizes, this
is really what you get
as a pro in this private context.
The next thing I wanna talk
about are student fees.
And indeed student fees are
often one of the first things
that come to your mind when you talk about
these private universities.
And indeed this is of course true,
so when I studied here
at University of Munich,
I almost paid no student fees at all.
Essentially studying
at a public university
in Germany is for free.
So this is of course different
to the private universities.
When I completed my master
in accounting and finance
in London, I paid over 20,000 pounds,
British pounds, in student fees.
And I recently checked again, the webpage,
today it costs even over 30,000 pounds.
This is of course a crazy
amount, and can be very
detrimental for other people
trying to study in this way.
So how can you do it?
What can you do to finance this?
And indeed there are lots of
opportunities for scholarships,
I would encourage you really
to check out scholarships
that might be available to you,
I was privileged enough to
pay at least a significant
portion of the total student
fees with scholarship programs,
of course the exact programs
that are available to you
depend on your country, on the university,
on your region, so do this research.
Though my opinion also is
if you really wanna do it,
if you have a dream university
where you want to study,
there are ways to make it work.
I would very likely not, not
study at such a university,
only due to the student fees,
there are often ways to finance it,
and indeed after you
study at such university,
especially if you study something
in the area of business,
you really often have
opportunities to then also
recoup, remake the money rather quickly
after graduating, at least
if you then also have
the goal to move into
one of these high paced
careers that then provide
you with the salaries
that would also enable you
to pay back the student loans
that you might potentially
take to finance this.
The other question that of
course people have in mind
when talking about public
versus private university,
is the whole discussion of target schools,
is the whole discussion of
whether or not it really helps
your career to study at
these private schools
potentially because they are
considered a target school,
which is a school that
is a preferred university
for employers to hire from.
And indeed now reflecting
on my experience here,
I think the first insight
is that you will always need
to distinguish local target schools
from global target schools,
because the University of
Munich, even though it is
a public university, could
be considered a target school
in Germany, so this
university has the reputation
in Germany that it is one of
the leading business schools.
And indeed all these employers
that we so frequently talk
about on this channel, like
the MBB consulting firms,
McKinsey, BCG, Bain, and so
on, they do like to hire people
from the University of
Munich, and indeed I was hired
for an internship at
McKinsey when I was studying
in the middle of my bachelor here.
Though the truth is also probably
if you go beyond Germany,
if you go beyond the country,
very few people will really know
the University of Munich.
So it is a local target school.
And now you can compare this to a school
like the London School of Economics,
in the UK, in England,
this is of course
university which is probably
well known also far outside of the UK.
Many people in many
other countries will know
this university, so this
university that might be
considered an international target school.
And if you want this type of reputation,
if you want to study at university,
with a reputation that
exceeds the boundaries
of your region, of your country,
it might be worthwhile to go there as well
and yes of course in
terms of target schools,
in terms of later
potentially also applying
to an MBA, or to other
larger global firms,
this might be helpful,
though I would argue
most of your career ambitions
can very much be fulfilled
with studying at a public
university which is a local
target school as well.
So I hope that these
different considerations,
these different dimensions
that I looked at
are helpful to you if
you are in the position
to now ask yourself
whether you'd like to study
at a public or private university.
But what is my personal conclusion?
What is my reflection on this question?
And personally, I would not have wanted
to miss my time in Munich.
It was for me an extremely
remarkable and formative time.
And indeed just also from
the cost perspective,
given that the undergraduate
degree usually goes
three to four years, now
the need of having to pay
students fees for all this time,
this is of course insane, and
it's arguable whether you will
recoup this financial burden
then later in your job.
But what I think could be the sweet spot
is to indeed do the undergraduate degree
at a public university,
benefit from the lower cost,
from this very remarkable
experience that you get there,
and then get for the private
university the master degree,
because the master often
is only one to two years,
so the cost will be lower,
there you can then get
also all these benefits without incurring
all the cost.
This is in the end how I did
it, and reflecting on this
it did make a lot of sense
for my personal career,
and also looking back at some of my peers,
many people followed a similar
route and it worked out
quite well for them as far as I can tell.
So now I'd like to hear from you.
What are your experiences?
Did you study at a public
or a private university?
If you studied at a private university,
what are your reflections?
Was it really worth your money?
I'd love to hear from you,
and indeed as you know
every comment that you
leave below the video
also helps me with the algorithm.
And indeed, if you took
any value out of this video
at all, please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm,
and also subscribe
to my channel to stay up
to date on all my content,
I release new videos
every single Saturday,
and if you wanna see even more from me,
also follow me on my Instagram,
my handle is FirmLearning.
I now wanna say thanks to all
the members of the channel,
you're really making a great
contribution to the cause
of this channel, thank you so much,
and to all the others of
you, good weekend to you,
hope you are having great days,
see you back next Saturday, this is Heinie
from Firm Learning, bye bye.